hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on borderlines 3 again
and today is gonna be video 2 of the
three crew challenges for DLC 1 the last
video we covered the DLC once kiddin
head locations that was for the mayor
today we're gonna be tackling toward and
in the next episode we'll be doing ember
and all of her resistance type statue
fire explosion things whatever you want
to call those we're gonna be tackling
those next episode of course maybe by
the time you're watching this they might
already be out but of course spoiler
warning ahead we will be showing some
the endgame areas because that's for
some of this stuff is rhetoric there's
about five or six different locations I
believe and you also get a whole new
legendary pistol called the vigorous
scuffle I believe is the name so that
we're gonna be showing that at the end
of the video and also do be aware that
in some of the sections I actually end
up just throwing my TD or gun and
blowing up some of the bottles my
controller has major stick drift and I
can't really parkour and go on small
ledges without falling off so I just
said [ __ ] it in through the bottle so
that's what that was for if you're
wondering you probably can climb up to
those areas but I just did it the
easiest way because it was a pain in the
ass yeah I was always like to be if you
do enjoy subscriber for new the
timestamps for all the stuff will be in
the description down below now let's get
started with today's video
[Music]
you